you may have heard rumors that chat G
pt4 is going to be released imminently
say in January and that it's going to
dwarf chat GPT 3's ability just like you
can see in this graph well I'm going to
let Sam Alman correct the record here on
both fronts and then at the end of the
video I'm going to discuss what I think
chat gp4 will be capable of here's Sam
Alman on the timing of the release of
chat GPT 4 can you comment on whether
gp4 is coming out in the first quarter
first half of the year it'll come out at
some point when we are like confident
that we can do it safely and responsibly
um I think in general we are going to
release
technology much more slowly than people
would like we're going to sit on it for
much longer than people would like then
referring to chat G pt4 he talked about
whether it will be an exponential
increase in terms of its abilities or
more of an incremental upgrade given the
magnitude of the economic impact we
expect here uh more gradual is better
and so putting out a very weak and
imperfect system like chat GPT um and
then making it a little better this year
a little better later this year a little
better next year that seems much better
than the alternative then Sam directly
addressed the hype train that had been
generated by Graphics such as this one I
saw a visual and I don't know if it was
accurate but it showed GPT 3.5 versus I
guess what GPT 4 is expected and I saw
that thing on Twitter did you was that
was that compl no okay that was
a little bit scary um the the gbt 4
Rumor Mill is
like a ridiculous thing I don't know
where it all comes from I don't know why
people don't have like better things to
speculate on I get a little bit of it
like it's sort of fun but that it's been
going for like six months at this
volume people are begging to be
disappointed and they will be like it's
you know people are going to like the
hype is just like we don't have an
actual AGI and I think that's sort of
what is expected of us and you know yeah
we're going to disappoint those people
in a moment you're going to see Sam
respond to a question about chat TPT
putting Google out of business and he
made a fantastic point which I'm going
to go into more detail on after he gives
his remarks yeah I think whenever
someone like talks about a technology
being the end of some other giant
company it's it's usually wrong like I
think people forget they they get to
make a counter move here and they're
like pretty smart pretty competent the
counter move that Sam is referring to
May wellb Palm which is a 540 billion
parameter Transformer model and you can
see from the graphic the improvements
that have been made by increasing the
number of parameters but I've done some
research on Palm see this graph notice
the Line crossing the performance of the
average human it admits when you go into
detail about the tasks that Palm can
achieve that we're still talking about
solving 60% of problems that 9 to 12
year olds can solve and that is
incredible so the average 12-year-old
can solve 60% of them and palm can Sol
58% of them but that isn't exactly AGI
not yet at least so if chaty bt4 is
anywhere in that kind of ballpark we're
going to notice the difference we're
going to see the Improvement just as
that graph increased quite dramatically
by increasing the number of parameters
maybe it will be able to explain jokes
for example understand books a bit
better but we're definitely not talking
about AGI not yet I am certain that the
initial Buzz around Chachi bt4 is going
to be amazing I'm going to let Sam
address the difference between the
initial Buzz the impressive achievements
it can do and the robustness of the
entire model one of the sort of strange
things about these Technologies is they
are impressive but not robust and so you
use them in a first demo you kind of
have this like very impressive like wow
this is is like incredible and ready to
go um you use them a 100 times you see
the weaknesses and so I think people can
get a
much sort of a false impression of how
good they are however that's all going
to get better the critics who Point
these problems out and say well this is
why it's like you know all like a like
you know fake news or whatever are are
equally wrong thank you for watching and
do subscribe for more such content